looking good Jeff but beige McGregor's
really lighting off my board oh do you
know I named my vagina God that woman is
a cancer by Jeff oh god here comes up
weird little stay-at-home mom oh my god
what is she wearing maddie was up all
night barfing on my hair but it's going
i'm very happy karosa case you just
gotta sadness all over me here comes Amy
just don't know how you leave your kids
all day and go to work oh yeah but i
also need things like money right I'll
see you guys later just love how hard
she would such a hard worker I just said
that Vicky got four minutes to get raspa
to the vet this should be fine you're
super late for your marketing meeting I
can't believe I'm gonna be late to my
first soccer practice you having a bad
day it could not get any more I called
this emergency PTA meeting to address an
issue that affects the safety of our
children terrorism
the bake sale this is a joke what's not
now I can't do this anymore I'm done in
this day and age it's impossible to be a
good mom screw it bad mom I'm in just
somebody moved my stool Amy hi I was
like to see if he's like to join me at
the movies this afternoon we allowed to
do that this literally been the best day
of my life pta meeting it to it when we
see you there no I I learned the PTA
nobody takes class but plays the
clarinet unless I say so she's ain't
bully you have to take down these
perfect moms I say we go punch that
chick right in the tips yes this is the
best PTA meeting ever
i havent have sex with my divorce well
if i get someone who's not circumcised
run out of the room screaming it's like
finding a gun in the street just scream
and get out of there oh I love my baby